remember last time you came and you
brought us these mugs and then and then
I didn't what I didn't realize at the
time is mugs is like a fixation of yours
you love mugs I love I did bring you
guys mugs they arrived after they was so
kind after oh you got them I never I
never knew if they went into the ab of
male no no the mugs are beautiful but
that means we never thanked you and I'm
sorry so thank you sorry well the MS did
say drop dead on
them and why confused it it was a weird
thing they were beautiful mugs and it's
so beautiful I still have mine mine said
never again never yours said never again
mine said drop dead and you're said
never have children oh my God that's
right you all got the wrong ones oh yeah
I was supposed to get no children yours
is Rob dead that makes sense doesn't
this make sense you love mugs but you
need them to have a very hostile message
on yes it it cuz it makes you happy and
then immediately steals your joy it was
sweet because you are among I think
Randall Park was the only other person
to bring something he brought whiskey
and and we're not putting it out there
that people need to bring something we
are yeah bring but these were like
wonderful little equestrian mugs with
chocolates in them and it was so kind we
still drink out of that mug to this day
how do we yeah oh my gosh I'm so happy
to know that they made it here my mug
was sent to the con Brian Museum in oh
God in Orlando
Florida what else do they have there uh
it's your mug oh it's um Jesus there's
not no it's not a lot it's a pillow that
Al roer leaned against oh okay
1994 some of my original Pomade wow
there's it's not a well visited Museum
not a lot of people go there no uh but
also they do uh they do a free Lube job
there we got a lot of you mean car
cars oh but also lubricating people that
want sex yeah wait what did you mean I
thought I thought you were talking about
an an oil change but you meant okay cuz
you said Lu job okay so they're
lubricating genitalia well they do both
at your Museum maata can come in well
it's just a thing to try and get people
to visit the museum it's in someone's
basement wow we say it's a
museum look it's just it's really more
of a trap than a museum okay but anyway
that's an important it's Orlando check
it out God honestly it's Florida doesn't
surprise me at
I we the people in Florida know and
they're like whatever it's fine they're
like we got so much to deal with
run your little fake Museum trap your
Lube job your Lube job Museum don't care
over there like we got real problems
here they don't care over there oh man
I'm so glad you loved your mugs I love
coffee mugs That's My love language you
know what's interesting whenever I'm
anywhere that's my big weakness is if
they I look and see do they have a you
know in some of these travel shows that
I've done over the years I always want
to find is there a mug here if when I
was on the DMZ the line between North
Korea and South Korea I was like do you
have any mugs and I mean I'm I'm just
always looking for like a line down the
middle of it like half north and half
they have a gift shop at the DMZ and to
to access the DMZ you have to drive
you're on a road that and either side of
the road is mined it's filled with
landmines it's crazy one of the craziest
experiences I've ever had and uh you
drive along
and um I went there with Steven young
yeah and we get there and there is a
room that's half in South Korea half in
North Korea oh my gosh and so we shot a
little bit there where he he did the
weather from the window that looks out
on South South Korea and I did the one
that looks out of North Korea but then
there's a gift shop and you've never
seen a gift shop like the one they have
there all kinds of stuff and I was just
my main Obsession was I've got to get a
coffee mug that's what I do I get the
coffee mug mugs from wherever we go I
also make a ton I have like I put
pictures on them and give them as gifts
I'm obsessed with that but I can't so
hotels and stuff makes me crazy cuz the
mugs are always like small like
cappuccino mugs exact that's this is a
this is a mug good mug I love this mug I
don't know someone gave me this mug I
wish I could remember or maybe I found
it I can't remember but anyway this is
the correct size he's holding a
well-sized mug in his hand yes I have
large hands I'm a large man and I need a
big mug and uh this is the size and I
know what you mean those little what is
that shot of coffee so I have to travel
with my mugs and I travel with my coffee
Mak that's crazy well I have it I
brought it here so if you have a choice
between you have a choice between
bringing your daughter or your special
mugs I'm you leave your daughter at a
motel a th% I need my mugs cuz I need my
coffee to deal with her are these
ceramic mugs would these break or they
like travel I pack them very well wa I
pack them very nicely or I'll make sure
I have one when I arrive I'm a real Diva
you guys when I travel yeah you can't
call you
mama hey mama where's your mug M you
dare will you send someone out for some
Taco Bell really quick I know I had this
whole facade of being really easy breezy
but not at all you still you still have
the craving for the Taco Bell I love
Taco Bell son freaking love son used to
when when Sona was working full-time as
my assistant I remembered how often we'd
be driving around and we would pass a
sign for taco like a uh would would pass
a Taco Bell and you would always say the
same thing you'd be like I could murder
me some Taco Bell right now and then you
would go through the whole menu yeah but
I love that it was very aggressive like
I could go in there and Massacre some
Taco Bell yes I love I love Taco Bello I
and we're not getting paid right now by
Taco Bell don't tip toe around Taco Bell
you do you devour it you you do murder
it that's what it's there for you know
cuz it's going to murder you later so I
had an incision made in my body that can
be open where you can just push the taco
yeah and the doctor said 50/50 chance
you die from this operation and then the
doctor said is this so you can shove
Taco Bell directly into your and I said
yes and he said we've done many of these
yeah and I put it in with the rapping
doesn't matter W with the wrapping
you're Savage I am Savage you are you're
living on the edge the rapping the
wrapping I don't you just done my Taco
Bell pork you might want to get an
MRI or get it checked out are
expensive I've been a lot of pain but
I'm
[Laughter]
not